あっはーんドンキホーテのもの全部買ってみて
そういう企画にして
f してくださいつまり今日は両立月の初め社長です皆さん
パン付きですまぁ坊鍵を公民でした飯を食わないんであのコンビのパンツ求めてるん
ですけども排気の今皆こんなにおいしいねえほんと最近な公民のバーおいしいすぎって
あのえっと月全社で買ってきました
めっめっちゃリアー生ちーっ
[音楽]
オフいく黒金レバー
パン屋さんじゃあ初めて子連れになるのがローソンに僕が見た感じ売ってたパン全部
買ってきました今皆パン全種類ですもう何かあ
玉を幸福パンとかやばのパン屋さんやた4番から惣菜パン
ほんとしょうがパンダよりだ
キンクロの半分半分やを
パリとあらゆるパンぽいもの全部買ってきたんですけどもう本命のパンでおいしくない
ものがないんですよ僕が生きている限り僕は食ってきた限りおいしくないものはないの
でこれ全部混ぜて食うと美味しいんじゃないかっていう単純な僕の発想のことを今回は
動画を進めていかせせてくださいちゃん得意ますんでちゃんと汲んで俺だけじゃ無理だ
かこういう立つとと組んで全部マザーズ
ダッジをという二を感じてみたいですよ
年明けに全部混ぜてねがぐるぐるしてもちょっともったいないんで一切れずつ集めて
って各パーツをとでひとまとめにして食べてみようと思いますでは以下の4種類あるん
だろう
50くらいかな太鼓と種類のパンがありますこの後としてはいけないのターンを一切れ
ずつ組み合わせて混ぜて食うと果たして何なずになるのか混迷の版てねよーく考えて
作られているんですよ
もう計算建てられて美味しい作られてるんでそれぞれ混ぜて来て美味しいことは間違い
ないと思うので今回やってみようと思います常に僕がコンビニのパンでよく食べるのは
ダイエットをするときはこの
米 gopan いつも食べてましたねこれすごいダイエットに効くみたいです i
フィールドコンビニチュロスがあるんですよね行きなさいこのカレーパンにハマってい
た時期もありましたねあーたまごパンね
ダメだな
は普段果たしてどんな味になるのでしょうかとりあえずひと切り努めていきます
ね矢部くん2層入りの一地域でてもらっていきましょうズレスパーンと言ってはもう
これでしょ焼きそばパンパソコンと微量でいいんだよな
50個があるタブすごいようになっちゃうんでめっちゃわずかにもらっていきます線7
よくあるやつなんか公ゴンと行くってだ
超ジップティック板チョコ乗ってる奴これ中免で何たっちょこーちゃんと入れてあげ
たいところだ
どんどん把握していきますまずでが過ぎておかしくなっちゃう卵パンッ
そこでプロんぱんウィンナーのやつ
ええええええ
パパ連敗中でグッズが出た
違う枚か皆さん見ましたかこういうふうに包丁で遊んでいると気がするんですよを付け
て下さいね値11人
マヨネーズみたいな奴だな日目のカレーパンフロッサーもちろん色が
4実は5番松木とマーガリンの入ってるやつチョココロネホットドッグっぽいパン
スティック著僕はシャターろわーちょこちょこっとチョコのパンダー坐骨はクリーム
確定してや
切った
[音楽]
me
ん
2分
mh ん
ていません
段付ですメロンパンはいっ
できました溶存なパンを一切れずつ全部集めたものです
これをこれからどうしようかと言いますとこのままだとまだパンではないのでこれを
一晩泊まるにしていこうと思います
た
はぁ
[拍手]
はいいただきます
me
[音楽]
car
uh
me
car
あっはぁ